we're all weirdly symmetrical right now
Marine have some posture would you hey
guys I'm Ryan right you go next
Alyssa and Murray welcome to the channel
we're gonna watch the trailer tonight
for transformers age of extinction
trailer number two everyone in the world
has been asking me to do this I can tell
you're excited not really yeah me Oh
Alyssa that's how you do it it's okay
okay all right you got to get Murray in
the frame a little more Murray just get
more comfortable with me would you
okay that's too comfortable Murray is
too comfortable what are you doing what
are you doing already oh I'm trying and
I'm doing what you asking me to do okay
what are you doing I do this [ __ ] that's
right get back here come back we love
you I kind of like you come on really
though I'm so psyched for this trailer
like well the first Transformers came
out I loved it so much that I saw it
seven times in the theater and the
seventh time I thought in the theater it
was almost out was in like this super
super small one that only has like a
couple rows right you mean like one of
those Hispanic theaters no there's only
one aisle and then the chairs and then a
wall my family asked me to go get you
know drinks and popcorn all that good
stuff and I didn't want to miss the
beginning cuz I loved it so much so I
decided to sprint well I didn't know
there wasn't another aisle on the other
end of the theater so I sprinted
straight into a wall a concussion
wow it's legitimately one of my
favorites the first one only the first
one so I hope this one's gonna be okay
cuz the last ones have not been I was
not aware that there was another
Transformers movie coming out until you
posted the other trailer reaction for
this movie the other day okay I haven't
seen any trailer reactions for this at
all so I'm like oh yeah yeah no one
watches trailers anymore it's always a
trailer reaction now you've changed the
world around you what we like when you
go to the theater this is what you're
going to see ramela
yeah you see my face on the big screen
looking at the tree
snowy there this is the greatest advance
in modern physics since the splitting of
the atom rare metal Wow
molecularly unstable cool that was a
cool looking garden it's what they're
made of
okay so my favorite already all righty
you don't even see Mark Wahlberg I don't
even care all the way made of bumpers
but other never seen a truck like this
before
dad he keeps spending money on junk dad
I think we just found a transformer
so this is like a whole cast and
everything yeah
after all we have done you guys not
appreciate our hunting us is mister this
year we are all targets now
what is that you said you hear Wow
yes everyone loves Michael did this he's
not war
it's human extinction
oh my god
sacrificing and I have a prize maybe not
more we can be there's a message that
particular one looks like baby Jonah do
the action looks amazing you can
actually tell what's going on
dude this one's gonna be happy oh hi max
oh that's what it's all about that's how
you get a girl man you take them to IMAX
what do you think I rave about it so
much it was about an ax man ah these
trailers always get me and then I walked
out disappointed but these this one
looks like you know what I have faith in
this one actually it looks badass yes I
thought yes yes yes yes I thought the
first Transformers movie was real dumb
but I'm excited for the dinosaurs
Dinobots I think is what they're called
it's gonna be [ __ ] sweet did I know
he watched the show it was like a 3d
show that was like transformers but they
were all like animals and there were no
people and a morph no no no that wasn't
my kind of shows books and also TV show
no but there was AI it was oh man stupid
you know if I can't remember what it is
it's not like was it like in the 90s yes
Oh char kids no no it was like
specifically I'm pretty sure was a
transformers um was it transformers
there was a TV show but I mean it was
like they'd sing well figured out
fascinating story marine fascinating
facts yeah well what more can you say it
looks like a badass action film in Mark
Wahlberg's a [ __ ] yeah got a daughter I
wanna bang she's from Bates Motel oh
yeah oh good why I talked her on the
phone before I met her she said I'm a
very expressive person like kind of cop
no no no I said you were me he did yeah
and I was like okay a lot of girls say
that but she is this is not a camera
performance think this is a her we just
watched the yes dance video and she yeah
I've never seen somebody who's that rude
[ __ ] who kept their phone on
well if you guys are new to the channel
subscribe
we got wrap this video up cuz the girl I
ever had a first kiss with is coming
over her name is Vanessa she never
watches this channel so I can talk I
could tell you secrets about Vanessa and
she would never find out none of my
friends actually watched it like my
friends so don't come on the channel
they don't watch bastards that's why I
like you guys more [ __ ] my friends Tyson
Cole 2008 you need to get updated my
friend you're six years behind maybe
I've been perfect 2008 oh wow oh yeah
six year old subscriber I'll do that all
the time give this a thought people born
in the year 2000 or going into high
school right now
Wow which means if you used to know Tina
oh just four more years than a bunch of
18 year olds will swarm out of the
schools which happens every year I don't
know why I haven't pursued this yet well
thanks ty Nicole you gave me an idea for
2018 Erin Alejandro ali-han go Adi Hondo
you actually spelled that way a copy and
pasted your name Ali Hondo
did you is that a mistake what that
actually is real and there is no end
mmm wait there's an endless there's no
are there like a fiber did he said he
will do bad things to me if I don't give
him a shout-out wait that are like bad
you mean like like that where to go I'm
pointing to it look good Alyssa rot over
it's what you think it is it's the real
deal
she said hey look what I got and I said
okay yeah she says for horses whatever
we need they're all for a food Peter
Grayson I like that last name just like
Dick Grayson the famous character from
Batman Richard Grayson
Peter Grayson it's come coded like Peter
Parker and Dick Grayson ah I don't know
Peter can you call it an ego yeah Peter
Grayson I'm proud of you man way to
choose a good YouTube name just like
Murray hmm what is your youtube name
Murray you should call your son alright
seriously like how did that's like a
real name oh and she hasn't like made an
actual account that's just what we call
her oh she doesn't know I don't really
use you too much glider on the channel